jeden tag berichten wir über die hölle
von mario pohl über die eingeschlossenen
in dem stahlwerk dort aber wie soll man
sich die hölle vorstellen wir alle haben
das nicht erlebt im gegensatz zu anna
die mit ihrem baby dort zwei monate lang
in der unterirdischen bunker hölle
versteckt war ohne tageslicht unter
ständigem russischen beschuss mit einem
baby doch sie konnte gerettet werden sie
hat es heraus geschafft nach sabrina wo
unser reporter philipp ihr job sie
getroffen hat und sie kann uns
beschreiben wie die hölle aussieht
sein bild ging um die welt blauer
schnuller und knopfaugen der kleine
swiss life sitzt mit seiner mutter anna
evakuierungs bus in mariupol später dann
noch immer mit blauem schnuller aber
weißer mütze in sapporo sie endlich in
sicherheit
sechs monate ist der knips alt zwei
monate davon verbrachte er im finsteren
bunker des stahlwerks am samstag ein
drittel seines jungen lebens
und er
hat zum ersten mal gras gesehen er kam
im oktober zur welt als es schon kalt
war und jetzt hat er gras und sogar
bewohnen gesehen das sind nur
kleinigkeiten aber nachdem wir dort
waren sind diese vielen kleinigkeiten
wie ein ganzes leben
mutter anna sind die entbehrungen der
letzten wochen ins gesicht geschrieben
auch die sorge ums las papa der immer
noch im stahlwerk die stellung hält im
interview berichtet sie uns von der
drückenden hoffnungslosigkeit
am schrecklichsten war es morgens
aufzuwachen und zu verstehen dass du im
bunker bis nachts schläft man ein und
versteht dass der tag vorbei ist und
morgen vielleicht etwas neues passiert
aber morgens wachst du auf und es ist
dunkel und du verstehst das alles beim
alten ist
zwei monate hat es gedauert bis endlich
ein evakuierungs korridor für die rund
150 zivilisten im unterricht wurde
und selbst während der evakuierung sind
die geretteten überwiegend frauen und
kinder aus dem stahlwerk russischen
schikanen und propaganda ausgesetzt
wir alle haben eine filtration
durchgemacht frauen haben uns durchsucht
wir wurden komplett ausgezogen sie haben
nach regierungen gesucht wir mussten
erklären was unsere tattoos bedeuten
unser ganzes gepäck wurde durchsucht
sogar kleine kosmetikartikel oder
nagelfeilen wurden abgenommen sie
wollten es so hinstellen dass die asus
kämpfer uns nicht rausgelassen haben ich
möchte es noch mal sagen as of hat uns
geholfen mit allem was sie hatten die
jungs haben ihre gesundheit ihr leben
für uns her gegeben sie haben uns ihr
essen ihr wasser ihre medikamente
geblieben wir konnten das stahlwerk
wegen der musischen luftangriffe nicht
verlassen
der jungen mutter ist es wichtig die
russischen medien berichtet zu
korrigieren so auch beim schlimmsten
moment ihrer zeit im bunker
das war der tag als eine evakuierung
stattfinden sollte wir sind in den
pavillon gegangen ich stand mit meinem
sohn swiss life beim ausgang und wir
hörten plötzlich ein lautes geräusch das
war die explosion einer mine die vor dem
ausgang explodiert ist einer der
soldaten wurde sehr stark von splittern
verletzt ein anderer am bein da waren
auch zwei russische gefangene einer der
kriegsgefangenen wurde getötet ich sage
dass für den fall dass es in den
russischen medien kommt das waren nicht
unsere soldaten die ihn getötet haben
ihr habt euren eigenen mann getötet
an momente wie diesen wird sich anna
wohl noch ihr ganzes leben erinnern
söhnchen zwar schlaf ist mit glück für
solche erinnerungen zu jungen doch er
bleibt für alle zeiten das bunker baby
von marie
[Musik]
und wir gehen zu unserem reporter
philipp die torfabrik der mit anna
gesprochen hat philipp wie hast du sie
erlebt wo er nahm sie die kraft das
alles durchzuhalten
das kann ich bis jetzt auch selbst gar
nicht antworten dass diese junge frau so
viel durchgestanden was sie zwei monate
in diesem bunker überlebt hat mit ihren
schon etwas älteren eltern und auch
natürlich mit dem kleinen baby aber
jetzt sind sie zum glück hier angekommen
hier angekommen hier in die bresche ich
finde gerade in dem hotel in dem noch
ganz viele flüchtlinge aus dem stallberg
sind auch anna mit ihrem kleinen
schwertes lassen hier hinter mir sieht
man die einige der flüchtlinge aus dem
stahlwerk zu geradezu abendessen wie
möchten sie natürlich nicht dadurch
stören weil diese menschen wirklich
jetzt nach diesen strapazen nach dieser
hölle zwei monate lange bunker 48
stunden auf der flucht jetzt natürlich
etwas vor verdient haben was hat sie
über die anderen erzählt die dort noch
eingeschlossen sind es konnte gerade die
meldung vom bürgermeister von mario pohl
das ist wieder heftigen beschuss gibt
wie lange werden die noch durchhalten
können
ja man macht sich riesige sorgen
natürlich um ihren ehemann der einer der
soldaten ist die noch immer im stahlwerk
sind im römer kämpfen die gestern abend
als die luftangriffe begann das die
bodenoffensive also der sturm des
stahlwerks begann der riss die
verbindung ab zudem kämpfen die immer
noch unter dem stahlwerk sich befinden
und bis vor kurzem gab es auch was
überhaupt keine lebenszeichen aber jetzt
soll es wieder kontakt geben es gibt
erste meldungen auf twitter die wir
natürlich noch nicht bestätigen können
denen zufolge die offensive die boden
rufen sie wird der russen auf das
stahlwerk gescheitert ist aber die
sorgen sind natürlich riesig denn der
ehemann von anna ist verletzt er kann
nicht mehr laufen er ist also im
lazarett kann sich selbst nicht
verteidigen und wenn die russen das
stahlwerk wirklich stürmen dann ist er
wahrscheinlich dem tod geweiht
wer jetzt beschreibt uns doch mal die
situation in korea wo du ja bist
vielleicht auch rosa borussia
und wie ja wie die situation dort im
moment ist
also bisher ist eine stadt im südosten
der ukraine
also mehrere hundert kilometer
südöstlich von kiew die front ist hier
ca 30 40 50 km entfernt jemand nachdem
in welche richtung man fährt wir sind am
sonntag mal die fluchtroute des busses
abgefahren also zumindest demokratisch
kontrollierten gebiet und das wirklich
ordentlich geknallt kann man sagen wir
waren im ort namens war richtig und wir
waren ca 2 stunden lang da da gab es
zwei dutzend atelier einschläge die
soldaten sind immer wieder in die bunker
gerannt und allein in den zwei stunden
in denen wir da waren zwei zivilisten
von russischen raketen getötet worden
vier weitere wurden verletzt porsche
selbst ist bislang weitgehend verschont
geblieben zum glück muss man sagen denn
hier kommen jeden tag dutzende manchmal
hunderte flüchtlinge an aus mario pohl
und das sind menschen die schwerst
traumatisiert sind ja hier gibt es immer
wieder raketenalarm aber zum glück
passiert nicht so viel und die
flüchtlinge die hand kommen können sich
ein paar stunden manche ein paar tage
ruhe gönnen du hast gesagt nur 50
kilometer von der frontlinie entfernt
wir müssen wir uns den alltag dann
vorstellen du bist jetzt eben einem
hotel wir können es draußen nicht sehen
sind die menschen ganz normal unterwegs
auf den straßen oder bleiben alle
zuhause
nein die menschen sind so weit es geht
normal unterwegs auf den straßen zu
gehen und cafés und restaurants
natürlich gehen sie aber vor allem
arbeiten denn auch wenn die frontlinie
man könnte sich ja kaum vorstellen nur
50 kilometer entfernt es herrscht
wirklich noch normalität weil die
menschen ja auch gar nichts anderes
übrig haben sie können ja nicht den
ganzen tag zu hause sitzen den ganzen
tag sich bei jedem licht alarm und davon
gibt es hier viele in den keller rennen
und dort verstecken die menschen haben
sich daran gewöhnt dass es immer wieder
luftalarm gibt sie haben sich daran
gewöhnt dass immer wieder auch raketen
fallen auf die stadt aber sie machen
trotzdem weiter so normales irgendwie
geht natürlich haben einige menschen den
ort lassen aber es sind eben deutlich
mehr dazu kommen fast immer aus den
besetzten gebieten aus mario pohl sind
hier in die stadt gekommen und die
wollen nicht weiter gilt können aber
auch nicht weiter weil sie niemanden
haben weil sie kein geld haben deswegen
sind sie froh dass sie hier überhaupt
bleiben könnt und späten natürlich jeden
tag dafür dass die front ich noch mehr
kommt für liebhart auf aussah borussia
für die st philipp